you guys there is the latest version of
iOS out this is Iowa's 12.2 when I think
about how far we've come in iOS like
it's super shocking one of the most
exciting things obviously there's a ton
of other updates in this update but
there's also for new animo G's so we
need to check those out immediately so
in addition to the an emoji is there's
obviously the Apple News Plus
subscription so that's now available you
can now ask Siri on your phone or your
iPad to play any game or sports or
channel or movie or video or anything on
your Apple TV so that's kind of cool you
can basically use Siri to control your
Apple TV it was update to Apple pay so
you can now instantly transfer your
money from your Apple pay account to
your account let's see what else that
was all right for airplay you can have
dedicated TV controls of control center
screen time o downtime can be configured
with a different schedule for each day
of the week that's nice because what if
I want to have more fun on my phone on
the weekends I don't know or less fun
there's no support for air pods to Apple
music the Browse tab shows more
editorial highlights ok supports air
quality index in maps for the US UK and
India I didn't even know that that was a
thing this is all great no what about
the an emoji I don't even have an an
emoji made on this phone I don't think
so
here's the new an emojis we've got a
giraffe we've got a shark which is gonna
be so great for Shark Week look at this
little owl and what are you are you a
wild boar I haven't even configured
myself an emoji
That's not me I used to have one and
then I don't know where it went your
style
give me my beautiful luscious locks does
that look like me
it does look like me advice my spaghetti
hair
spaghetti wait a minute where my hair so
though eyes I always thought that I had
brain eyes and my mom said that she
didn't think that I had green eyes
I do have darker eyebrows than my hair
because what do you know where's not
this color old school nose and lips okay
okay what about this one oh yeah look at
that we look alike I don't have facial
hair wait I do have earrings and we were
smearing to myself so what that I don't
think this looks like me I think my lips
are too vague like what do I think I am
Kylie Jenner no absolutely not
I also feels like my eyes don't really
have big eyes I also think my head shape
is often new that looks better
okay nobody's that one hey Jenna how's
it going
do I look cool what she's gonna get so
annoyed no I thought I'd test out the
giraffe
oh my gosh it's so funny Wow hi Jenna do
you wanna I don't know I don't know I
would say baby
it's Shark Week show bring your teeth is
it sparkly yet
[Music]
people look so crazy when they're making
these in two minutes a look if I'm a big
smile I'm into it now I got dizzy from
shaking my head around so freaking fast
[Music]
are we having fun are we going to the
mall later it's always a weird because
you can hear people making like mouth
sounds who's there making there an emoji
the shark is probably my favorite hey
guys I'm a shark I'm having a good day I
hope that you are as well
let me show you my beautiful teeth
these are so good like the giraffe also
like he's so cool look at him he's so
cool I think I did a good job of making
my momochi look a little bit like myself
hmmm my hair a little bit longer but
it's okay well I just wanna show you
guys some of the new man emojis because
I think that I really really really like
the shark like I think it might be my
favorite an emoji that they have made to
date look it's so perfect it's so great
just in time for Shark Week I'm just
getting it so excited for all of the fun
new Apple announces this year I have
been actually using this iPad so much
like way more than I ever thought that I
would I'm gonna follow up video on this
very soon as my necklace been messed up
this whole time or like well somebody to
tell me or what shark week no remember
what is Shark Week I don't see any
movies matching a shark playing nearby
for this week okay
well you tried solid effort I'm getting
so excited for all of the fun tech this
year like it's just already so
overwhelming just thinking about all the
crazy things that are gonna be coming
out so we've got things to make videos
about let me know what you guys are most
excited about like what's your favorite
piece of tak like when I make videos
what are the things that you like
watching me test out the most I look
forward to hearing what you guys think
and in the meantime I will see you in
the next video so have a nice day or
night or evening or whatever the time is
for you
[Music]